Thank You spider-man I'm so good
hey I am late happy nice thank you you
too thank you
new dress yes it is hot you know what
just happened
[Music]
get your passport Peter Parker here to
pick up a passport please
mini to space let's go pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood spy
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no it's not I'm messing with you
you look pretty too I suppose spend some
time with nd I'd like you to be my first
time I love I had just finished my phone
call so nice to finally meet you
spider-man
your Nick Fury what some clothes on
let's go for a ride
is she gonna be okay like that might
want to turn him over so he doesn't
swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker but a job to do
are you going to step up or not
we're all alone your friends are in
trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit in my really respective sup
dickwad
you